Robbie stop ray recently yeah I can't I
did yeah I thought that was gonna have a
little bit later but yeah pray man yeah
sorry yeah
Scott Butterworth and I we saw the first
hour of what is led to believe as the
the full game which was kind of
frustrating or I would say unfortunate
because the first half-hour of the game
is kind of like just like half hour they
gave me his story beaten and it wasn't
until about halfway that through that
hour was when you actually caught got
this kind of experiment right so this is
very much like a dishonored Bioshock
they're always different like like real
clear but tasteful I would say
inspirations but I had a pretty good
time with it it's it was kind of
endearing in a way where I wanted to
continue to play that unfortunately we
didn't see any of like if you've seen
any of the gameplay trailers the powers
you get to eventually kind of take from
these creatures called typhoons mm-hmm
and like the aliens in the game those
are the aliens in the game that board
this science lab Space Station and tear
it apart mm-hmm
but yeah you know the gameplay trailers
like we're so cool you just turn into a
cup mm-hmm and then use kinetic energy
to launch yourself over a wall but yeah
we need to see any of that so it was
very just like kind of immediate core
abilities you kind of have yeah and it I
want to talk about like you touched on
it how its influenced by Bioshock then
you go even back in farther mile shock
was as influenced by you know System
Shock 2 which Ken Levine it was his
first big game he worked on 'pray is
being made by Arkane studios which of
dishonored fame dishonored to fame with
Harvey Smith and Raphael Antonio the
latter of which is the one heading up
prey and obviously this is the reboot
they had there was that whole
controversy when Pete Hines from
Bethesda said something about no
arcane's not doesn't have rights to
Preto but then it turned out it was kind
of just uh you know facetious because
they have the reboot they were working
on anyway they have pray the reboot now
and it looks great and it looks like
Bioshock and it looks like System Shock
it goes back to the looking
the last days if you're familiar with
like a system shock or Ultima Underworld
back in the 90s this first-person
immersive choice consequence driven sim
I guess they described as which is like
Dishonored you know you have all these
abilities you have these different ways
that these levels can unfold there's
that zero four five one code that's the
number that's in all these games from
Ray Bradbury's really yeah Fahrenheit
451
so Bioshock it unlocks a door thief it
unlocks a chest I believe thief's made
by a looking-glass as well an ion storm
who did deus ex Harvey Smith worked on
it's in there as well and it's in
Dishonored 2 it's just very often a code
that opens a safe or anything it's just
in reference to Ray Bradbury's
Fahrenheit 451 the temperature which
books burn in that book in that story
but it's that's a really cool Easter egg
in all these games and if that's
actually like what I want to talk about
all the games I just mentioned kind of
how they're influencing prey and even
let you go back to dishonor to but pray
despite the fact that it's by arcane it
looks very different right obviously the
sci-fi elements the you know the more
horror elements then dishonored but in
terms of the choice and consequence
driven gameplay with how these different
powers can unfold and whatnot it looks
really cool and the fact that prey is
more is an open world on the space
station whereas this honor was these
discrete levels is also different
structurally but I'm really want to like
talk about because I know Callie you're
a really big shooter fan as well am and
I'm assuming you played Bioshock and did
you ever get the chance to try out like
System Shock or anything back in the day
or like no I'm a baby yeah I didn't play
until recently I didn't beat it it's
pretty tough it's yeah I'm successful
anymore but they're doing the remake up
in Portland I believe I forget the name
of the developer I'll look it up and
yeah we are looking at this right now
and I did a video today and I really
happy with it because for one I haven't
done a video feature in a while and this
was really fun to look at so I believe
this is two more in Lucy's video and I
kind of did it a touch on basically just
these guys were here called mimics yeah
and they are like it's kind of
unfortunately segue they're really
unique like I've never really seen an
enemy that essentially makes you
approach an open room and go okay right
this is great like okay okay watch this
right there yeah yeah three of them
flowerpot that yeah a pot a flower and a
radio so that happens a couple times
where you approach a room and they all
kind of like cooperate and we'll wait
like once I'm I killed one of them and
then like all right cool the room is now
like cleared mm-hmm and later on they
like we're in a corner the whole time
three of them just like waiting and then
they attack and like really messed me up
and so it's it's this really unique idea
of like like what's the purpose of
actually like you know knocking over a
object on a table in any other game
right right
here it's like there's a purpose because
you're trying to see which one of them
is an actual like alien yeah Scott
Butterworth editor who went with you to
the preview event he was saying that it
kind of plays with your expectations of
physics in games or even just the
environment right take it for granted
that these physics objects can like just
roll around but now you're actually
paying attention because it could be a
threat which is awesome right like you
look at the room one way the first time
you enter it so it's like its level
design that's like two for one if it's
two different purposes yes the second
time you look at once you think you've
cleared the room then you're like okay
it's such a great way to fit into the
horror of the game yes like always
uneasy it's exactly that and then
there's also the side a component of
sometimes these mimics are a little
obvious women like you go to a room and
like you eventually start learning like
how to like you know investigate
so you'll see like a pair of shoes and
then there's an extra shoe it's like
they're like they panic cause like
though sometimes if they're by
themselves they'll scatter and try to
basically like quickly it's like okay
what's in the room really quick ambolyn
gaming Ryan Schubert here at Cana just
posted Rob's future video the youtube
link so uh check that I have check that
out after the show copy that paste into
your browser knock it out not now it's a
really it's a good future but I'd rather
you watch let's talk right now yeah
anyways touching back you know stay here
so you know these guys are original but
yeah back to like
you know the inspirations I would say
what for me the first one was in light
of like Bioshock it was being underwater
right and seeing this place crumble one
of the first things this game does pray
is you kind of first get to a big open
area and then you know part of the
spacestation just explodes you see all
this stuff just eject into you know the
death of space and right away you're
kind of thinking about that right and so
it's that claustrophobic tendency as
well that you kind of are always
thinking about in that game it's very
similar to Bioshock no way yeah it seems
like the next the logical evolution of
you know rapture underwater Columbia
from Bioshock Infinite the sky and then
you go back to System Shock which is
also on a space station
it's these these games really love
taking these isolated communities and
showing how like I don't know to be an a
pessimist humans are always gonna [ __ ]
it up right rapture was a lot of a lot
of dystopian and sighs right stuff is
about humans [ __ ] stuff up yeah and I
was watching I was playing the Bioshock
collection recently on ps4 and I was
watching the developer commentary from
back in the day when a Jeff Keely
interviewed believers Nate Robinson and
Kemba bean for these commentaries and
they were saying rapture in large part
aside from the they actually thought of
doing an underwater city before they
decided to make it like this dystopian
Iying Randian kind of like Galt's Gulch
if you've read Atlas Shrugged this
isolate community of the brightest minds
in the world and how they just devolved
into this dystopia but they actually did
rapture at first because they wanted you
to feel like you were actually confined
in this world that they use the metaphor
I think they're in New York when they
were doing the interview so they're
saying we didn't want you to look over
and see New Jersey and feel weird that
you couldn't go there we want you to
look out into the water and know you're
trapped and just accept what you're
seeing which this space station seems
like the next logical evolution that
which is pretty cool in my mind like
Tacomas releasing by the full bar
company and a sometime this year they
haven't announced a release date yet but
it there's that vein of games that does
that really well even dishonored if you
want to talk about like well design
worlds you know you have at Eve which
kind of like feels you're plasmids in
Bioshock and you have Adam which is what
they pull from the slugs on the seafloor
which powers the Eve I might be
butchering that a little bit
but then you have there's always this
like very well formed world in these
games and it's integral to how the
mechanics work right it's whale oil it's
a whaling community in Dishonored but
also your powers come from the outsider
I believe his name is who gives you the
supernatural powers like blink and far
reach and everything and I think these
games are kind of back in the 90s they
were really ahead of their time but I
think I'm really excited because you
know dishonor dishonor to and from what
it looks like prey are kind of bringing
that back right and I'm really excited
for to see how prey will unfold in this
open world mm-hmm
not in the sense of like breadth of the
wilder horizon but this open mission
with on like within the space station
that you're exploring right rather than
discrete like distinct yeah just you had
those nine missions and it's I'm looking
forward to seeing how it unfolds yeah I
guess in this case they would be neuro
mods that you find a game oh it sucks
you have to yeah suck I was think that
the other day it was like hey if he's
doing this how many dozens of times like
you're I essentially it's like a
lookingglass base to kind of thing
needles like just taking like a
telescope I can open doors I can turn
into a cop now it looks unsettling it I
don't love stuff to do with my eyes I
value them know and they don't like
poking myself yeah why don't stabbing
well if I could change into a [ __ ]
microphone I would stab myself in the
eye in an instant the better way the
better way would be your nose right yeah
that but if you butchered that you could
actually kill yourself mmm cuz you would
just hit your brain a peck Spanglish
what you're doing right you're so fun
apex penguin just said the outsider of
dishonored started out as the penguin in
Gotham and when Batman finally killed
any pledges internal salt of darkness so
there's you to lure from Dishonored
you've learned something new every day
that's mine for the day now you're done
you're done learning for all intents and
purposes I'm really really excited for
prey I was just tweeting the other day
about how it might be my most
anticipated the game this year despite
the fact that breadth of the wilds on
the horizon
and horizon on horizon but I love Zelda
and it looks like it'll be a fantastic
game but right now I'm excited for prime
1/5 I believe it releases yeah I really
love everything arcane does even like
going back to arc state Alice days
they're kind of breakout hit designer
was kind of a breakout hit yeah 12 arcs
Vitalis earlier six years before that or
something was kind of they're showing
their stuff cuz they worked on a
Bioshock 2 a little bit as well I just I
love a good sci-fi I really hope that
the sci-fi set up continued like holds
up throughout the game like I'm super
excited to see how that goes and how it
meshes with the gameplay and the kind of
different kind of a mission that you're
going on as opposed to like we mentioned
Dishonored definitely I'm really looking
forward to it even like seeing maybe
some dead space influences outside of
the eyeball stabbing yes yes some of the
later horror elements I believe you know
the creatures I guess you could count on
them progressively getting one more
intense and there's one called nightmare
yes and this sounds awesome
you've seen the gameplay of it it's just
giant like gorilla but it can like still
manage like creep under doors but
essentially as you eventually get powers
and use the powers like that are from
the aliens that dude like senses it yeah
so it's that like he hunts you like I'll
like the Nemesis if you play rez exactly
it's like a procedural thing from what
I've done for what I understand yeah and
also one of my favorite pieces of trivia
about Bioshock 2 is that initially
Jordan Thomas who bled production led
development and keep like Steve Gaynor
at the former company in Carla's Omonia
who were are the Faubourg company now
who worked on Bioshock 2 the initial
intent with the big sisters which if you
remember if you play a Bioshock 2 which
is one of the most underrated games of
all time I will stick by that well the
big sisters we're not going to be
multiple Big Sisters gonna be one that
hunted you the whole time procedurally
and that sounded awesome but they
ditched that because they didn't think
people would be like okay with that in a
Bioshock sequel cuz the Bioshock fans
who came into Bioshock to be like it's
[ __ ] hard and terrifying I don't want
to deal with this right they ended up
it's making it like story beats sounds
like they're going for that with the
nightmare later on and pray though which
sounds awesome
which will just further increase the
terror you feel when that item that lad
in our studio can be a mimic or what or
when you oh it's turning to rats and
scattered no every time you walk into
room out you see a mimic like become a
trash can't really quick it's just like
a little kid who's like I close my eyes
they won't see me this is really funny
yeah we great would be great to be like
a cop right and then that guy comes in
the room no yes
yeah so I'm really excited for prey and
I'm excited to see how Bioshock system
shock deus ex kind of you know and
arcane's all their work on Dishonored
kind of transfers over to it so let us
know your thoughts kelly playing on
twitter rob handler at twitter magma
Hardy on Twitter I think we're all
pretty excited for this game so let us
know what you think
[Music]